over the years series finales have
become more than just the end of the TV
show now they're bona fide cultural
phenomenon leaving fans talking for
years let's take a look at some of the
greatest vinyl episodes of all time and
fair warning
we plan to totally spoil the ending six
feet under
HBO six feet under blended quirky and
poignant elements as well as any series
in recent memory so it isn't surprising
that its finale was a little bit of both
fans of the Fisher family watched in
stunned silence as youngest sibling
Claire left California for a job in New
York as the deserts Airy flash past her
window we saw flashes of the future for
the rest of the main characters in
typical six feet under style we've got a
glimpse of what happens to the whole
Fisher family including how they all age
and die one by one if you're not crying
by the end of this one you're already
dead inside Star Trek The Next
Generation entitled all good things
the final Star Trek The Next Generation
episode marked the end of seven great
seasons of highly acclaimed television
the series frequently explored social
ethical and philosophical issues as the
crew probed the depths of space and the
finale was no exception
Captain Picard finds his mind jumping
through three points in the same
timeline forcing him to think outside of
the known laws of physics to solve the
anomaly forced upon him by the
omnipotent obnoxious being Q that are
the cure alike some are almost
respectable Picard manages to solve the
conundrum returning to a scene from the
series first episode and proving to Q
that humanity's potential is limitless
much to Q's surprise the show ends with
a love letter to fans as the captain
joins a poker game with the other crew
members for the first time I should be
bonus what I'm proud of a girl Breaking
Bad during its five-year run Breaking
Bad evolved from just another TV drama
into a cultural phenomenon when the
series finally drew to a close in 2013
fans eagerly anticipated an episode that
promised to
wrap up an epic saga of crime greed and
vengeance and the show absolutely
delivered Walt returns from hiding and
manages to secure his family's future
exact his revenge and saved jesse from
captivity before going down in a blaze
of glory the way the final scene played
out was a direct punch to the gut for
fans as bad fingers baby blue plays in
the background walt lovingly examines
the meth lab jesse was forced to work in
and even as the sirens approach in the
distance you wonder if he might make it
out alive after all until he collapses
to the ground succumbing to a bullet
wound Buffy the Vampire Slayer
out of just Whedon's many television
series Buffy the Vampire Slayer is
perhaps the most beloved generating
legions of fans who still obsess about
the show to this day for the finale
Whedon pitted the Scooby Gang against a
malevolent enemy in a battle that
required the characters to work together
in one last showdown in the depths below
Sunnydale high as you might expect from
a show that never shied away from
mortality not everyone makes it out
alive after the survivors flee from the
wreckage and the School Bus
dawn poses the question many fans were
asking as the credits rolled
yeah Murphy
what are we gonna do now Friday Night
Lights
MBC's high school football drama Friday
Night Lights was always more about the
cost of characters than the sport itself
appropriately enough when millions tuned
in to the finale
they were treated to an episode that
focused on the lives of the characters
long after the last pass was thrown and
the cheers of the crowd faded away with
the state championship in the past the
characters are shown in the future with
many storylines neatly wrapped up most
importantly Coach Taylor finally got to
move on building a new life for himself
with his wife in Philadelphia
[Music]
yells come
sons of anarchy from 2008 to 2014 sons
of anarchy lit up our screens with its
high-powered intense crime drama
chronicling the lives of Jax Keller his
extended family and the other members of
the SAMCRO biker club the final
installment of this often bloody always
exciting one Shakespearean tragedy was
just as bloody and tragic as the rest of
the series Jax eluded police on a
high-speed chase until deliberately
driving into the path of an oncoming
semi ending his own life while many fans
praised his decision as a selfless way
of saving his children's future Jax
still managed to be completely selfish
in the end just think about that poor
truck driver probably scarred for life
by the incident